[Musica]
ciao a tutti molto bello essere qua a
rimini
quando mi hanno proposto l'argomento
della velocità l'ho trovato veramente
interessante perché nel nostro mondo
andiamo anche troppo veloci e spesso ci
dimentichiamo di quello che è successo
prima di noi
in particolare nel campo della medicina
noi pensiamo di sapere tutto di sapere
come sconfiggere le malattie spesso
guardiamo alle malattie come se fossero
fenomeni fissi e terni immutabili questa
in realtà vengono dal passato e sono
soggette a cambiamenti e mutazioni nella
stessa misura in cui lo sono gli esseri
umani gli animali e le piante i vegetali
oggi si parla in tutto il mondo di muri
di mura dividere e separare i muri sono
sempre esistiti questo è il vallo di
adriano separava nell'attuale gran
bretagna il mondo romano la parte
conquistata dall impero dalla parte
all'epoca abitata dai cosiddetti barbari
non avrebbero apprezzato il termine ma
lo stesso concetto che politicamente è
qualcosa di assai controverso nel nostro
mondo
in realtà viene sottovalutato quando si
tratta di medicina questo vallo di
difesa per la nostra salute spesso non è
fortificato in maniera adeguata e
patogeni che un tempo erano liberi di
devastare intere popolazioni possono
tornare ma vediamo qual era la
situazione nel mondo antico
come dicevo l'umanità nel corso della
storia ha sviluppato armi sempre più
potenti capaci di uccidere tantissime
persone nel 1918 il paris piaciuto era
considerato il cannone più potente era
kalpa era capace di colpire parigi da
130 km he uccidere tantissime persone
nel 1945 la bomba atomica fatta detonare
in giappone fu considerata l'arma più
potente
eppure quel micro organismo che vedete
la il virus del vaiolo e
esisteva già da millenni e da almeno 300
400 anni aveva questa forma pandemica
epidemica estremamente mortale e nel
solo ventesimo secolo ha causato tra 300
e 500 milioni di morti una cifra
enormemente superiore ai 100.000 200.000
morti causati dalle due bombe atomiche
sul giappone al termine del conflitto
la mia professione è quella di
paleopatologo studio come le malattie si
presentavano nel passato questa
disciplina è a metà tra la storia della
medicina che studia come progredita come
progredito il pensiero medico e l'arte
medica e l'analisi clinica di scheletri
antichi mummie anche fonti storiche
quando la disciplina è sorta la pratica
era molto poco seria perché come potete
vedere in questa famosa rappresentazione
le mummie venivano liberate dalle band
che le coprivano in occasione di un
party fra gentiluomini dell'impero
britannico
oggi invece disponiamo di strumentazione
molto più avanzata ma è sempre bene
ricordare che la nostra non è mai una
semplice analisi medico biologica è un
insieme di approcci multidisciplinari e
quindi bisogna evitare vedete sulla
sinistra quella che al grande autore
inglese jonathan swift chiamava la
battaglia del libro sia una guerra tra
gli autori antichi e moderni la guerra
tra le discipline umanistiche e le
discipline scientifiche si tratta di
guardare allo stesso oggetto da
prospettive diverse che poi vanno a
complementarsi questo sta mancando molto
nel mondo moderno alle volte però è un
po come immaginava il grande filosofo
francis bacon è un po attraversare le
colonne d'ercole e andare per un viaggio
che non sappiamo dove ci porterà come
dicevo oggi disponiamo di tecniche molto
più avanzate non abbiamo solo le
tecniche morfologiche che ci permettono
di studiare anatomicamente con tessuti
antichi
disponiamo di tecniche radiologiche
tecniche paleo molecolari possiamo
addirittura ricostruire l'antico dna di
virus che sono vissuti centinaia e
migliaia di anni fa tantissime malattie
croniche quali la chrome egalia il
gigantismo che la malattia che si
sviluppa a partire dall'età giovanile
esistevano nel mondo antico questo è
dimostrato dalle raffigurazioni per
esempio dell'imperatore massimino il
tracce ma è stato dimostrato ho avuto il
piacere di coordinare questo studio nei
presunti resti del faraone egiziano sun
act 2.700 avanti cristo
questa malattia esisteva questo è il
celebre caso studiato da grande medico
inglese john hunter e poi dal chirurgo
americano harvey caching la malattia è
stata scoperta solo 100 150 anni fa ma
era ben presente nel mondo antico
un'altra malattia cronica la gotta il
mal patrizio avrete tutti letto nei
libri di storia di quanto ricca di
proteine fosse la dieta delle classi
agiate e questi nobili poi finivano per
sviluppare dolori articolari causati
dalla gotta ossia la precipitazione di
cristalli di acido urico questa malattia
è stata descritta in maniera accurata
anch'essa negli ultimi 150 anni
ma potendo combinare le fonti storiche
abbiamo visto come colpisse i personaggi
dei ceti più elevati dell'antichità per
esempio federico da montefeltro non
abitava tanto lontano da qua le fonti
storiche riferiscono che soffrisse di
gotta termine molto vago all'epoca
eppure abbiamo dimostrato nel primo
metatarsale questo ossicino del piede
destro una cavitazione tipica della
precipitazione dei cristalli di acido
urico confermato dall'esame radiologico
e poi abbiamo trovato una fonte
archivistica in cui si dice il duca
scrive al proprio medico che soffre di
un terribile dolore al dito del piede
destro questo ci permette
di combinare il dato archivistico con il
dato tecnologico moderna fino a qualche
tempo fa addirittura non si aveva la
certezza della presenza dell'ictus
nell'antichità ed è stata proprio una
mummia qui della provincia di rimini
ossia un corpo naturalmente preservato
sì grazie alle condizioni micro
ambientali che è stato possibile
dimostrare la presenza dell'ictus alla
metà del settecento in questa mummia di
don giovanni arcangeli un parroco della
zona
abbiamo trovato un grado di contrazione
dell'arto estremamente sospetto che non
ci faceva pensare ad una modificazione
post mortale e abbiamo poi confermato la
cosa radiologicamente trovando anche una
calcificazione all'interno dell'arteria
carotide che va a portare il sangue al
cervello e nella fonte archivistica
abbiamo trovato che questo sacerdote
dovette lasciare la conduzione della
propria parrocchia o morbo apoplettico a
causa di un colpo apoplettico a causa di
un ictus
queste malattie croniche sono sempre
esistite
nell'antichità oggi sono solo più
frequenti perché sono tipiche dell'età
avanzata oggi viviamo più a lungo perché
sono migliorate le condizioni igienico
sanitarie
disponiamo di antibiotici ma disponiamo
anche di un'arma fondamentale qual è la
vaccinazione che ci permette di bloccare
all'origine a priori prima ancora che si
manifestino processi patologici
potenzialmente mortali
benché già nell'antichità alcuni autori
avessero notato questo fenomeno della
immunizzazione il primo grande
scienziato che produsse un vaccino
abbastanza sicuro e capace di salvare
tantissime vite fu jenner il quale e
innestando il vaiolo bovino su di un
bambino lo protesse dal vaiolo umano e
come vi ho detto prima questa malattia
era devastante nella antichità il
morbillo è
una malattia che per lungo spazio di
tempo ha avuta la stessa pericolosità
del vaiolo negli ultimi trecento anni il
vaiolo invece è diventato molto più
aggressivo eppure lo stesso morbillo può
uccidere come lo dimostra
quest'ultimo anno 37 persone sono morte
in europa a causa del morbillo
se voi aprite un testo di medicina della
fine dell'ottocento quale quello del
grande medico canadese william osler
vedete che la terapia era
sostanzialmente inefficace oggi la
situazione è la stessa ma all'epoca non
c'era quello che abbiamo oggi il vaccino
che ci permette di bloccare all'origine
il processo patologico
purtroppo anche grandi personaggi
intellettuali si sono opposti alla
vaccinazione quale mezzo di prevenzione
efficace il grande lord byron uno dei
padri del dl del romanticismo che morì
in grecia combattendo per la libertà del
popolo greco di si vaccini sono una moda
passeggera
prima o poi le persone se ne
stancheranno o un grande artista moderno
a robert de niro in seguito all'autismo
sviluppato dal figlio ha continuato a
sostenere la fallace associazione
vaccino trivalente autismo derivata da
una frode scientifica del dottor
wakefield 1998 poi radiato dall'albo dei
medici britannici perché aveva fatto una
frode aveva falsificato i dati senza
permesso per produrre una evidenza
scientifica da cui lui poi avrebbe
derivato un vantaggio personale
il vaiolo è una malattia potenzialmente
antichissima
già forse ramses quinto fu il primo fast
faraone egiziano a soffrirne nella
storia ma come vi dicevo è stato proprio
lo studio delle mummie a dimostrare
recuperando il dna di questo virus che
solo dal xvi secolo si ha avuto un
vaiolo veramente mortale letale la
poliomielite quest'anno avrebbe dovuto
essere radicata secondo le
previsioni dell'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità eppure ancora presente nel
nostro mondo in africa in asia e
continua ad uccidere questa malattia era
forse già presente nell'antico egitto
non vi è una certezza definitiva dalle
rappresentazioni artistiche ma la si può
intuire in alcune mummie quali quella
del faraone sip da è difficile però in
questo caso rinvenire rna del virus che
ci darebbe la prova definitiva
un altro esempio per lungo tempo di
pollo nell'antichità è stato il caso
stato considerato il caso biblico di
melfi budget di cui parla il william
osler di cui vi ho accennato
precedentemente ma all'epoca quando non
si conosceva il virus della polio la
colpa di questa infermità di questa
disabilità dei bambini veniva attribuita
alle donne in particolare alle donne che
si prendevano cura dell'educazione dei
bambini che li allevavano quindi il
progresso scientifico anche permesso un
progresso sociale importantissimo per
quanto riguarda i temi della salute la
pertosse continua ad uccidere in europa
ea ripresentarci questa malattia
proviene dall'asia dove si sviluppò in
forma epidemica nel quindicesimo secolo
tra afghanistan e in iran
alla fine giunse in europa e diedi una
grandissima epidemia in francia
descritta da gi and the bay il malato
sembra gonfiarsi come se stesse per
strangolarsi trattiene il respiro
per non parlare del tetano una malattia
sottovalutata anche da tantissimi
operatori quali archeologi lavoratori in
cantieri e anche nel caso di disastri
naturali il tetano è una malattia che
non può essere eradicata perché le spore
del clostridium si trovano nel terreno
ovunque ma noi possiamo prevenire questa
malattia che altrimenti ci porta a morte
tra spasmi atroci luigi carlo farini
nell'ottocento
medico molto famose patriota italiano
trovandosi di fronte all'impossibilità
di curare un paziente rivederlo
agonizzare morire di tetano disse io
sono certo che un giorno il progresso
medico individui individuerà la gente
responsabile di questa malattia e
troveremo la cura per questa malattia
oggi disponiamo di questa cura e
scegliere di non proteggere la nostra
salute e quella dei nostri bambini è
qualcosa a mio avviso di sconsiderato
nelle antiche raffigurazioni anatomiche
che troviamo un po in tutti i testi
antichi troviamo una frase latina it
morse caubet soccorrere vite qui la
morte si rallegra di poter giovare alla
vita
la paleopatologia e la storia della
medicina ci permettono di scoprire come
le malattie si presentavano in passato e
quali trend ed evoluzioni hanno avuto
nel corso della storia
un po come un tempo non si conoscevano i
continenti e gli oceani si navigava a
vista
un giorno ricostruendo l'antichità delle
malattie sapremo tutto di come queste
sono venute nel nostro mondo come hanno
interagito con i nostri antenati e come
si potranno presentare in futuro e la
speranza generale è che il contributo
delle materie storico mediche possa
portarci un giorno a guardare con gli
stessi occhi con cui i nostri padri
hanno guardato nel 1980 la sconfitta del
più grande nemico della specie umana
il vaiolo grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]